Empezaré compartiendo un poema
escrito por mi amiga de Malaui,
Eileen Piri.
Eileen solo tiene 13 años
pero al ojear la colección de poesía que escribimos,
encontré su poema muy interesante,
muy motivador,
que se los leeré.
Su poema se titula "Me casaré cuando me plazca".
(Risas)
"Me casaré cuando me plazca.
Mi madre no puede obligarme a que me case.
Mi padre no puede obligarme a que me case.
Mi tío, mi tía,
mi hermano o mi hermana,
no pueden obligarme a que me case.
Nadie en el mundo
puede obligarme a que me case.
Me casaré cuando me plazca.
Si me pegan
me echan de casa,
incluso si me hacen daño,
me casaré cuando me plazca.
Me casaré cuando me plazca,
no antes de terminar la escuela,
y no antes de ser mayor.
Me casaré cuando me plazca".
Este poema puede parecerles extraño,
y escrito por una niña de 13 años,
pero de donde venimos Eileen y yo,
este poema que acabo de leerles
es un el grito de guerra.
Soy de Malaui.
Malaui es uno de los países más pobres,
muy pobre,
y donde la igualdad de género es cuestionable.
Habiendo crecido en ese país,
no pude tomar mis propias decisiones en la vida.
Ni siquiera sabía que podía contemplar
oportunidades personales en la vida.
Les contaré la historia
de dos chicas diferentes,
dos hermosas niñas.
Estas chicas crecieron
bajo el mismo techo.
Comían la misma comida.
A veces, vestían la misma ropa,
e incluso los mismos zapatos.
Pero su vidas acabaron siendo diferentes,
tomaron caminos diferentes.
La otra chica es mi hermana pequeña.
Mi hermana pequeña tenía solo 11 años
cuando quedó embarazada.
Esto duele.
No solo le dolió a ella, sino a mí también.
Yo también pasaba por un momento difícil.
En mi cultura es costumbre
que una vez llegada a la pubertad,
se supone que las chicas tienen que ir a los campamentos de iniciación.
En estos campamentos de iniciación,
se les enseña a complacer sexualmente a los hombres.
Hay un día especial,
que se llama "un día muy especial"
donde un hombre, que es contratado por la comunidad,
viene al campamento
y duerme con las niñas.
Imaginen el trauma que estas jóvenes
sufren todos los días.
La mayoría de las niñas quedan embarazadas.
Incluso contraen VIH y SIDA
y otras enfermedades de transmisión sexual.
Mi hermana pequeña quedó embarazada.
Hoy, a sus 16 años
tiene tres hijos.
Su primer matrimonio no duró
ni tampoco su segundo matrimonio.
Por el otro lado, está esta chica,
que es increíble.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Digo que es increíble porque lo es.
Es fantástica.
Esa chica soy yo. (Risas)
Cuando tenía 13 años,
me dijeron que ya era mayor,
que había llegado el momento
de ir al campamento de iniciación.
Yo dije: "¿Qué?
No iré a ningún campamento de iniciación".
¿Saben lo que me dijeron las mujeres?
"Eres una chica estúpida y terca.
No respetas las tradiciones de nuestra sociedad, de nuestra comunidad".
Dije que no, porque sabía qué quería.
Sabía lo que quería en la vida.
Yo tenía muchos sueños de pequeña.
Quería educarme en la escuela
y encontrar un trabajo decente en el futuro.
Me imaginaba abogada
sentada en una gran silla.
Era esto lo que me imaginaba
y me pasaba por la cabeza todos los días.
Y sabía que un día,
aportaría algo, un poco, a mi comunidad.
Pero todos los días, a partir del día que me negué,
las mujeres me decían:
"Mírate, ya eres mayor, tu hermana pequeña ya tiene un bebé.
¿Y tú?"
Escuchaba lo mismo todos los días,
y las niñas escuchan esto todos los días
cuando no hacen algo que la comunidad quiere que hagan.
Al comparar mi historia con la de mi hermana,
me dije: "¿Por qué no puedo hacer algo?
¿Por qué no puedo cambiar algo que ocurre desde tanto tiempo
en nuestra comunidad?"
Fue entonces cuando reuní a las otras chicas
iguales a mi hermana, que tenían hijos,
y que fueron a la escuela pero se olvidaron de leer y escribir.
Le dije: "Vamos, podemos recordar y ayudarnos
a volver a leer y escribir,
a sostener el lápiz, a leer, a tener un libro en la mano".
Pasamos un rato muy bueno juntas.
No solo que aprendí mucho sobre ellas,
sino que también me contaron sus historias personales,
a lo que se enfrentaban todos los días
como jóvenes madres.
Y yo decía:
"¿Por qué no reunir todos los detalles de lo que nos está pasando
y comentarlos a nuestras madres, a nuestros líderes tradicionales,
y decirles que todo esto no está bien?"
Era un reto aterrador
porque estos líderes tradicionales
ya estaban acostumbrados a las cosas
como eran desde hace ya mucho tiempo.
Era algo difícil de cambiar,
pero merecía la pena intentarlo.
Así que lo intentamos.
Fue muy duro, pero insistimos.
Y estoy aquí para decirles que mi comunidad
es la primera comunidad donde, después de que las niñas
insistieran tanto a nuestro líder tradicional,
nos apoyó y decidió
que ninguna chica ha de casarse antes de cumplir los 18.
(Aplausos)
En mi comunidad
fue la primera vez que una comunidad
tuvo que cambiar los estatutos,
escribir la primera ordenanza para proteger a las niñas
de nuestra comunidad.
No nos detuvimos allí.
Seguimos delante.
Estábamos decididas a luchar por las niñas no solo en mi comunidad,
sino también de otras comunidades.
Cuando se presentó el proyecto de matrimonio infantil en febrero,
nos presentamos en el Parlamento.
Cada día, cuando los miembros del Parlamento estaban entrando,
estábamos allí para decirles: "¿Apoyarán el proyecto de ley?"
Y no disponemos de mucha tecnología como aquí,
pero tenemos nuestros pequeños teléfonos.
Dijimos: "¿Por qué no conseguir sus números y mandarles mensajes de texto?"
Así que lo hicimos. Fue una buena decisión.
(Aplausos)
Así que cuando aprobaron el proyecto de ley les volvimos a mandar mensajes:
"Gracias por apoyar el proyecto de ley".
(Risas)
Y cuando el presidente firmó el proyecto
convirtiéndolo en ley, estuvo aún mejor.
Ahora, en Malaui, la edad legal para contraer matrimonio pasó de 15 a 18.
(Aplausos)
Es bueno saber que el proyecto se aprobó
pero les diré algo:
Hay países donde la edad legal para contraer matrimonio es 18
pero ¿no se escuchan gritos de mujeres y niñas todos los días?
Las vidas de las niñas se echan a perder cada día.
Ya es hora de que los líderes cumplan con su compromiso.
Porque al cumplirlo,
significa que tienen sus intereses en cuenta.
No pueden relegarnos a un segundo plano
y tienen que saber que las mujeres, como las que estamos en esta sala,
no solo somos mujeres, no solo somos chicas,
sino que también somos extraordinarias.
Podemos más que esto.
Y otra cosa para Malaui,
y no solo Malaui sino otros países:
Las leyes de ahí,
no son leyes hasta que se cumplen.
La leyes recientemente adoptadas
como las leyes que ya existían en otros países
hace falta que sean apoyadas a nivel local,
a nivel comunitario,
donde las niñas se enfrentan a problemas muy graves.
Las niñas se enfrentan con estos problemas y asuntos difíciles
a nivel comunitario todos los días.
Así que si estas jóvenes saben que hay leyes que las protegen,
podrán valerse y defenderse por sí mismas
porque sabrán que hay una ley que los protege.
Y la otra cosa que me gustaría decir
es que las voces de las niñas y de las mujeres
son hermosas, y las tenemos
pero no podemos hacer esto solas.
Los hombres también pueden ayudar defendiendo,
interviniendo y trabajando junto con nosotras.
Es un trabajo colectivo.
Necesitamos lo que necesitan todas las niñas en cualquier lugar:
buena educación y, sobre todo, no casarse a los 11 años.
Además, sé que juntos,
podemos cambiar estos marcos legales,
culturales y políticos
que niegan a las niñas sus derechos.
Estoy aquí hoy
para dar fe de que podemos poner fin
al matrimonio infantil en una generación.
Este es el momento
donde una chica y otra niña, y millones de niñas en todo el mundo,
podrán decir:
"Me casaré cuando me plazca".
(Aplausos)
Gracias. (Aplausos)